Liquidity has been one of the biggest
concepts in trading over the past few
years, and for good reason, because it
works. But, here's the thing. Most
people trade it completely wrong. Look
at this liquidity sweep right here. It
didn't work. Now, look at this one over
here. It did. So, why did this one work
and this one didn't? Well, I'm about to
show you a simple technique that I use
to instantly tell me when a liquidity
sweep is valid. And once I added this to
my trading, I broke the world record for
prop firm payouts and made two and a
half million dollars. So, most traders
online don't even understand liquidity,
and they teach it all wrong. And it
causes a lot of traders to make a lot of
common mistakes. So, here's how to avoid
them. Now, most traders, they blow
accounts chasing every single candle
that they see on the charts. And I did
the same thing for years. When I was
working, I'd have my phone and I traded
whatever I saw. I'd sneak away to the
bathroom or I'd take a peek right before
going into a meeting, and I'd watch my
account get destroyed because I thought
every move up or down was a signal to
enter. And that in general is just
emotional trading. So, how does
liquidity actually help us as traders?
Well, it provides context and it gives
us specific areas of interest where the
market might provide setups and targets.
Now, here's what liquidity actually is.
It's simply clusters of stop losses and
pending orders sitting at obvious
levels. So, the first thing that we're
going to try and identify when we sit
down in front of the chart is what are
those obvious levels? Well, one of the
biggest foundational concepts that you
need to understand as a trader are swing
points. Okay, swing highs and swing
lows. Overall, if the market's bullish,
it should continuously make higher highs
and higher lows. And as that market is
trending higher and higher higher, we're
going to have additional swing points
being created as the market trades
higher. So, each one of those swing lows
that get printed, right, the next swing
low should be at a higher price if the
market is trending higher. Okay, so we
have all these pit stops, and as the
market's trending higher, we have all of
these additional swing points that are
being created or swing lows that being
created as the market trends higher and
higher. And vice versa, if the market is
trading lower, right, we're creating
lower lows and lower highs, and on the
way down, we are creating these
additional swing highs as price trades
lower and lower. So, all of these future
swing highs should be printed at lower
and lower prices as the market trades
lower and trends lower in a bearish
market environment. Now, again,
liquidity just simply is clusters of
stop losses and pending orders sitting
at obvious levels. So, we've identified
the obvious levels. Now, what do I mean
by liquidity? Well, let's just assume
for example that we have all these
participants in the market. Okay, we
have institutions, we have retail
traders, we have professional traders,
we have banks, whatever. Now, as those
different participants enter the market,
there is liquidity that's being
generated because they place pending
orders in the market. Now, let's just
assume that one of those parties wants
to get long after the swing low was
formed. Now, they can get long at on any
one of these following candles. It
doesn't really matter. They can get long
in anywhere in here. But, where are they
actually going to place their stop
losses? They're going to be placing
their stop losses below the swing low in
the form of sell stops, right? Because
if they buy a market, in order for them
to exit, they need to sell. So, they
place a sell stop below this low. Now,
let's assume that there's another party
that is not yet in the market, but they
want to sell short on a breakout. So,
they can also place their orders below
the swing low in the form of what? A
sell stop. Now, you're probably
wondering, Kyle, why are these all sell
stops? Well, if you try and go into the
market, and let's say price is currently
trading up here, if you try and place
any other sell order other than a sell
stop below current market price, the
market is actually going to reject your
order. Okay, so you have stop orders and
you have limit orders. But, if you try
and set a sell limit below current
market price, it's going to reject.
you're only allowed to set sell limits
above market price. So, I just broke
down two participants that have very
different interests in the market. One
is already long and they're trying to
protect themselves by cutting their
losses short, or one is trying to get
short and they're trying to enter on a
breakout below the previous swing low.
Now, both parties are entering the
market and this is generating them
liquidity. Now, there can be one more
additional party that's trying to enter
in this specific market. And that's
somebody trying to get long below the
swing low. And the order that they're
going to have to place is what? Well,
let's just assume that they have an
order in here. They're going to set a
buy limit. So, we have all of these
different orders down here, but I don't
want to get away from the point that all
of this is one big liquidity pool. So, I
don't want to get away from the point
that all of these different orders down
here is one big liquidity pool. So, as
you can imagine for a bearish example,
it's very, very similar. So, if
somebody's trying to be short on this
specific market, where are they going to
place their protective stop if they
enter in here? They're going to place
their protective stop up here in the
form of what? Buy stops. right, I hope
this is making sense to you guys here
and breaking it down very easily. Just
remember, your stop loss is a stop
order. So, if you're short, you have a
buy stop. And if we're long, you have a
sell stop. Those are your protective
orders. Now, let's talk about the other
participant. Somebody that's trying to
get long on a breakout. They're going to
set what up here? They're also going to
set buy stops. So, anybody that's not
yet in the market that wants to go long
can set a buy stop. Now, again, you
cannot set a buy stop below current
market price. The market will reject
your order. Now, if you want to get long
on a breakout, if the market goes up to
that level, it's going to trigger you
into a long entry. So, that's
participant number two. Now, there's a
third participant. And the third
participant is somebody that's trying to
get short up here using what? A sell
limit. Now, again, you can only set sell
limits above current market price. Now,
one last time, I don't want to get away
from the point that all of these orders
up here is one big liquidity pool. Now,
here's the thing though. Understanding
what liquidity is and actually trading
it profitably are two completely
different things. There's a critical
filter I use to separate the real setups
from the noise, and it's the exact
filter that allowed me to take my
trading from break even to consistently
profitable. Now, if you're going to use
this exact strategy to trade prop firms
like Apex, the one where I made the two
and a half million dollars in a single
payout, I have a code that will get you
80% off all accounts. And I'll leave
that link in the description. Now, let's
talk about the filter. You understand
liquidity the right way. Now, you need a
system to find an actual trade, and I
created one that helps you find the best
one almost every single day. Now, let's
talk about swing failure patterns. Now,
what is a swing failure pattern? Well,
for a swing low, price goes below the
swing low, but closes above the swing
low, and that's a bullish swing failure
pattern. And vice versa, for a bearish
swing failure pattern, we have a swing
high and price goes above the swing
high, but closes below it, and that's a
bearish swing failure pattern. Now, I
want you guys to just think for a
second. Why do these patterns actually
work and why are they so valuable in my
trading system? Well, think about all
the traders that had their resting
orders below the swing low point. Right,
we had a bunch of sell stops and we had
a bunch of buy limits. Now, if this
market is going to eventually trade
higher, who do you think is going to
make the money there? Now, let's talk
about party one. They have a sell stop,
so they get stopped out at a loss. Party
two, they have a sell stop trying to
sell short on a breakout. Now, they're
trapped. So, anybody that tried to short
it on a breakout is now trapped because
the market's going the other direction.
Now, the third party, the person that
had a buy limit is the one that's
sitting in profit because overall, they
think the market's going to go higher.
And what they're going to anticipate is
on the next candle, we get what? A new
swing low. So, when we see these
patterns, we just want to think about,
okay, who's getting stopped out at a
loss, who's getting trapped in the
trade, but who's in profit? Now, because
they took out all of these orders, let's
just assume that the order book dries up
below the market, and now this new swing
low should be protected. Let's talk
about the different participants when it
comes to a bearish swing failure
pattern. Okay, we have our buy stops.
So, anybody that's short is getting
stopped out on a loss because they have
their stop loss above the swing low
high. Anybody that's trying to get long
on a breakout is now trapped cuz the
market has gone the other direction. And
anybody that set a sell limit up here is
in profit. So, because they took out all
of that liquidity, now this high becomes
protected. Now, I'm going to share with
you guys something that will save you
thousands of dollars and possibly years
of torture in the markets. What I used
to do was I would see these swing points
being taken out, and I would try and go
short immediately. Now, what I used to
do for many, many years was I would see
these swing highs and lows being taken
out. And what I tried to do was enter
position immediately, and I would get
stopped out because I didn't have a
proper area to put my stop loss. And
this is essentially you guys trying to
top and bottom tick the market. Now, all
of my mentors and a lot of veteran
traders that I talk to will always tell
me, you don't want to be the first
person in the market. Okay? And this is
the filter that saved my career. Because
what does it actually tell us? It tells
us all of these things after the fact.
We're not trying to anticipate. We can
clearly see on a chart what's happening.
So, instead of me trying to jump the gun
and go long as soon as we take out the
swing low, I'm going to wait to see if
the larger market participants are going
to try and push this price in the
opposite direction. Because once I have
confirmation that it's closed back above
the swing low, as I mentioned up here,
right, price goes below the swing low,
but closes above it. Now, all of a
sudden, all of these things have been
confirmed on the chart and I'm not just
guessing. Okay, I can see that the sell
stops are being stopped out at a loss. I
can see the sell stops that are trapped
because they tried to go short below the
low, and I can see the people that had
buy limits below the swing low, they're
now in profit. And that is the filter.
So, when we're trying to hunt our
trades, we're waiting for this
confirmation, and then we're going to
try and get in on the consecutive
candles after we get the confirmation
that all of these things are happening.
All right, enough of the theoretical
drawings. I'm going to actually show you
guys on a chart that this happens all
the time. And it doesn't just happen on
a daily time frame. can find these
setups on a lower time frame. I'm just
showing you guys the daily chart because
it moves slower, it's a little bit
easier to understand. Yeah, we have all
these swing lows. You see this swing
low? After we get a raid below the low,
what are we doing? We're waiting for a
closure because again, as we're taking
out the swing low, we're not trying to
pick the bottom. Okay, we want to see
other people pick the bottom, and then
we want to see a confirmation. So, after
we get a closure back above the low, now
all of a sudden, this low is protected
and we can try and find intraday entries
on the next daily candle. Okay, now,
let's say the market's trading higher
and higher and higher on all of these
consecutive daily candles. Now, there
probably is swing failure patterns on a
lower time frame. I'll leave that up to
you guys to study. Again, this is back
in December 2025, but let's say the
market is trading at a premium and we
want to get short. All right, we have
another bearish swing failure pattern
that appears right here. So, as you guys
can see, we rate above this high. So,
it's taken out all of that liquidity up
there. It stopped people out that want
to get short. It's entered people into
the market and now they're trapped
because it's going the other direction
and we have people entering sell limits
above the high that's in a slight slight
profit. Now, when we get a bearish swing
failure pattern, this high should be
protected. So, as you guys can see, it
never rated this high up here. Now, it
definitely could. So, we have another
swing high. This market could have
easily come up here and rated it again
before going the opposite direction. So,
I want to point out that this does not
work 100% of the time. But, once this
market really starts to roll over, we
can see all those different
participants, the ones that have gotten
stopped out, the ones that are in
massive profit. Again, the people that
are in massive profit had sell limits
above that high. But, what we're waiting
for is the market to turn and roll over
because again, we don't want to be the
first ones into the market. Now, as this
market rolls over and trades lower for
the consecutive days, there is plenty of
opportunities to get short. So, down
here we don't have an SFP, so maybe
there's not anything to look for, but if
you drop down to a lower time frame,
there is likely some sort of lower time
frame swing failure pattern that you
could take advantage of. Now, quickly
going over some of these other examples,
I want you guys to just study these
examples. As I mentioned, it doesn't
work all the time. So, we did have this
SFP. We got a closure back below the
swing high and then we only got follow
through for one day after that. Now,
again, we have another bearish SFP that
appears at this high, but it takes a
couple days to roll over. Then we come
back down and we take out this low and
we're waiting for a closure back above
and then we have consecutive days
trading higher and higher till we rate
out this swing high. Then we get a
closure on this candle and then it rolls
over and continues lower. And at the
time of this recording right now, it is
February 7th. On Friday, we actually
have a bullish SFP. So, coming into next
week, I am leaning bullish on the
markets. Now, you've got a proven system
for finding the best swing failure
patterns every single day, but here's
where most traders still fail. They find
the perfect setup and then completely
butcher the execution. They either enter
too early, too late, or they manage to
trade emotionally and give back all
their profits, or they're just not
confident enough in getting stopped out
numerous times and reentering. As I
mentioned in these examples, you could
have gotten stopped out multiple times
in here. But, if you don't get short and
you stay short on these consecutive
candles in here, you're going to miss
out on this run lower down to these
lows. And vice versa, if you get long
somewhere in here and get stopped out,
but you don't stick with the trade idea
and you're trying to get short somewhere
in in one of these candles, you're going
to get stopped out and miss this entire
move higher as it raids out the highs up
here. So, in this last section, I'm
going to just show you guys my exact
entry technique on a trade that I took
this past Friday and I'm going to show
you the risk management rules that allow
me to go from a struggling trader to a
seven-figure trader. Now, this part is
crucial, so I want you guys to pay
attention. All right, first, executing
and managing the trades. You have to
identify the swing failure pattern
first. So, this was Friday at 12:51 a.m.
Don't ask me why I was awake. The
markets were moving around a lot and I
just cannot sleep. So, we got a big old
SFP at the lows on ES. And we also have
an hourly bullish fair value gap. So,
I'm going to show you guys that SFP.
Now, this is the current candle. The
daily candle hasn't confirmed an SFP
yet. So, I'm showing you that this works
on a different time frame. And again, it
works on many many different time
frames. Now, if I were to go through
this chart right now, I could find you
dozens of examples of these SFPs
actually working. Okay? So, I'm just
pointing out a few here, guys. There's
plenty and plenty of opportunities in
here. Now, I probably don't need to show
you too many. But, we have this bullish
4-hour fair value gap and it's traded
all the way down here and this is
Friday, which typically we're looking
for a retracement into the end of the
week. So, again, I sent this message to
my Discord. We got a big old SFP at the
lows on ES and we have a hourly bullish
fair value gap. So, I'm going to show
you guys that right now. So, we have a
4-hour bullish SFP and this is a 1-hour
chart. Okay, so I just show you the
4-hour chart. This is our 1-hour chart.
On our lower time frame, we have this
bullish fair value gap. And what I
typically like to see after we get an
SFP is when I go on the lower time
frame, I'm looking for what? I'm looking
for displacement. Now, the fair value
gaps give us that displacement. I
typically will not enter fair value gaps
as it's trading into it. I know it's
probably the better risk reward, but I
actually like seeing markets trade away
from that level and reject it. So, I
wasn't really hunting those setups until
this candle here. And let's say if we
missed out on that candle, you may want
to enter on this candle and have your
stop loss below this low because it's
rejecting this smaller fair value gap.
And what are we going to do? I'm just
targeting the most recent swing high
because why? I know that there are
pending orders above swing highs and
swing lows. Now, you could very easily
use this swing high as well as a target.
Now, here's the results of that trade.
As you can see, we have this 4-hour SFP
down here, which is this black line. We
have our fair value gaps in here and
then we have this rejection from this
fair value gap. So, I entered long in
here and I did have my stop below these
lows. The screenshot that I took was
when I adjusted the stop loss and
reduced some of the risk. So, as you can
see, we got really really close to the
take profit here. I just ended up
closing this trade manually because we
did have news out at 10:00 a.m. and I
didn't want to risk giving back some of
those profits because of the news
volatility. So, going back over
everything and why I trade these setups
and why I think they're so effective is
because it's giving me context of the
market. It's telling me, okay, these
traders are getting stopped out. These
traders are in profit. And then I'm just
trying to get the meat of the move as
the market trends in one specific
direction. You now have a simple and
proven approach to liquidity, but
chances are this isn't the only reason
you still aren't profitable. I know this
because I struggled for 10 years before
I became profitable, which is why I
created the Trading Apprentice. This is
not your average trading Discord. It's
direct access to me, a verified
seven-figure trader and world record
holder, to teach you everything I've
learned in the last 14 years. I'll leave
a link to apply down in the description,
but I want to be clear. I don't work
with just anyone. If the link still
works, there are slots left. Otherwise,
you can join the wait list. And as
always, thanks for watching. Don't
forget to subscribe and I'll see you in
the next one.